how's it going my name is ha and welcome
to an update video you might have
wondered where I've been the last couple
days or most likely you just don't give
a [ __ ]
Thanks we actually moved and yes I know
and if I don't up did you Bros on
everything that goes on then that
usually just means I I get to see some
weird comment saying like oh yeah pivots
hasn't been uploading videos because
he's he loves ducks more now than us I
don't know I don't know we're still in
UK after all and I don't think you boys
need to know exactly what I hate if I
wanted you bros to visit my house then I
would give you my address and I'm like
almost every single day now I get
recognized when I go outside and that's
not something I'm getting tired of like
I I really enjoy it like it makes
whoever I made happy and it makes me
happy and don't be shy if you see me
like it don't don't be shy I'm nice I
promise Ramesh there's gonna be more
demon souls coming up I don't know if
you guys notice but lately I've just
been playing games and I really want to
play and I love that game and it's been
making it a lot more fun for me like I
think a couple months ago I would play
games more for you bros than for me I
think that's wrong I think if I don't
enjoy when I'm playing then then really
what's the point even though this is a
job job technically it really isn't for
me I want to enjoy it and I've been
focusing on that for the last month
couple months and it's just been making
YouTube a lot more fun for me and I
really do love it like I put so much
time into this every single day and
that's only because I really really love
it but I know ebro's are a little upset
I'm not playing amnesia as much anymore
honestly like the community of amnesia I
kind of faded away a lot with the latest
game not being that great or not being
what fans expected so and I know you bro
say I'll play any horror games or what
but I keep track of most of them that is
new and they're just if there's no one
coming out then I'm gonna play something
else and it's it's kind of annoying when
people get angry at me for not playing
these things when really I'm just trying
to keep things fresh for myself and for
you rose that's that's the only reason
why so I hope you realize that I'm not
like I'm not gonna play I'm a chef [ __ ]
those guys like it's because I don't
think it's anything worth playing right
now there's a ton of other great horror
games coming out like I'm honestly
routine forest looks amazing and the
evils within these are all coming out
pretty soon so there is coming just like
let them come like every time we get in
somebody comments it's like genuinely
upset that I haven't played among the
sleep and the game isn't even how it's
is like what do you want man I don't
what do you want man I had a little
angry bill tonight other than that I
would say thank you both for 17 million
subscribers or Bros Y what I just feel
I'm starting to feel guilty over having
so many of you like I don't feel like I
deserve it and I know you bros would be
like no you dish out of it really you're
great no I'm not I'm okay but I'm not 17
million worthy I don't I don't get it
but it's amazing like it's mind-blowing
I never thought I'd be this lucky I I
really do appreciate every single one of
you brother you're the reason they makes
it possible for me to do what I love
every single day and I am eternally
grateful for that
everything with YouTube has it's made my
life so much better I met my girlfriend
all these positive things has happened
and it's just been an amazing journey so
far and I can't wait to take it even
further I know I can't count around Lee
but I kind of
like we connected a little baby thank
you brother for all the support
let me bros it comes to breakfast Samson
in this episode we go into Bligh town
and you guys have warned me by blithe
tiny brush sentence icon there's a
[ __ ] nightmare I have my bath salts
I'm ready to do